our main story tonight concerns business
a word that somehow describes the front
part of a mullet the second nicest seat
on an airplane and the single saddest
room in any
hotel specifically we're going to talk
about the businesses that make other
businesses business their business
management Consultants there are three
big firms and tonight we're going to
focus on the oldest and largest one
McKenzie and Company he's been around
for nearly a century advising both big
companies and government agencies on how
to fix their most complex and Urgent
problems Mckenzie was founded in 1926 by
James o McKenzie he was a professor at
the University of Chicago and an expert
in management accounting by the 1950s
The Firm was assisting the White House
with Staffing organization which
according to the company would lead to
the creation of the chief of staff role
in 1970 McKenzie helped create the
barcode yes that barcode that's actually
true McKenzie did help invent the
barcode I know that's a little
disappointing maybe thought it was
invented by a grocer in the 60s who
dreamt of a away for computers to taste
fruit maybe you thought the beeps were
just how the program says yum but I'm
afraid that you're imagining a better
world than the one we actually live in
but it's not just barcode Innovation
firms like McKenzie sell themselves as
can do experts who can come in provide
an outside perspective and fix whatever
ails a company whether it's
re-engineering an organizational chart
working on digital strategies or
deciding whether to sell off part of
their business you name it they'll
advise you on what to do and Mackenzie
has worked with everyone from companies
like Coca-Cola Best Buy and AT&T to
government agencies like the Department
of Defense and Ice McKenzie is massive
and it's ubiquitous it has offices in at
least 65 countries and an annual revenue
estimated at $15 billion but McKenzie
doesn't see itself as just a bunch of
PowerPoint slinging power suit wearing
mic managers as you can tell from their
recruitment videos they see themselves
as operating as a Force for good in the
world our purpose is to create positive
enduring change in the world the work
you do with McKenzie will matter what we
are doing on a day-to-day basis is
really impacting the lives of thousands
of people sometimes more what's really
great about McKenzie is it provides you
with an opportunity to work on really
hard problems that are also really
interesting and also really actually
matter right Mackenzie Consultants are
encouraged to see themselves as World
Changers as a humble Mackenzie partner
once put it there are only three great
institutions left in the world the
Marines the Catholic church and McKenzie
which is a hell of a group to put
yourself in look there's just three cool
guys left in the world now Henry
Kissinger Kevin spacy and
me and the truth is McKenzie's
reputation has taken a bit of a knock in
recent years it's found itself under
scrutiny for everything from
exacerbating income inequality to
helping Market dangerous products to
enabling authoritarian regimes and
former employees have pointed out that
for all its talk of making the world a
better place it's worked for some of the
planet's biggest polluters while getting
hundreds of millions dollars in return
in fact one of those disillusioned
employees paints a pretty damning
portrait of what the company is at its
core they serve a lot of clients with
really harmful effects they know exactly
what the repercussions are going to be
and then they say we're going to do it
anyway and that tells you all you need
to know about the firm right that's an
inherently alarming thing to hear about
a business isn't it generally you want
companies to mitigate harm not actively
seek it out it's why Lego has a choking
hazard warning on its packaging instead
of one that says now with blue raspberry
flame so if it's that influential that
ubiquitous and is behind so much harm
tonight let's take a look at McKenzie
and if this is the first time that you
are hearing MacKenzie's name don't be
embarrassed because for a company with
so much reach it's gone out of its way
to try and keep a low profile it doesn't
publicize its Client List and even its
offices can be hard to spot we stopped
by MacKenzie's headquarters at three
World Trade Center in lower Manhattan
well that's such a powerful company and
yet you'd never know they were here
there's not a single Mackenzie sign
anywhere why is that they don't want
anyone to know anything about them uh
they want everything done in secret and
if that includes where they work then so
be it well that's not innate suspicious
at all is it you've sealed yourselves
inside an expensive glass fronted
nameless Lair that is completely
invisible to anyone unless that is they
simply type McKenzie into Google Maps or
happen to hear that journalist say three
World Trade Center while she literally
showed you their address kogs by the way
that was a dick move and I genuinely
appreciate it but discretion is only
part of MacKenzie's brand they've also
cultivated reputation for hiring the
best and brightest fresh out of elite
colleges and MBA program programs and
young High achieving types often use a
stint at Mackenzie as a springboard to
bigger things former employees include
Pete budded Senator Tom Cotton
Facebook's Cheryl Samberg and Google CEO
Sundar pitchai and McKenzie picks its
Consultants through a notoriously
rigorous interview process asking
candidates challenging and slightly
unconventional questions one of the
interview questions I was asked in my
final rounds was how many pigs are in
China which sounds like a very silly
question but it's a really good question
to test how you think
because it's not only the answer doesn't
matter it's how do can you structure a
problem can you take a very nebulous
situation and put structure around it in
a way that makes sense and then
logically deduce things in order to get
to an answer that's meaningful I mean
sure that is one way to describe it
another way might be to say that they're
just trying to see how good you are at
bullshitting your way to a plausible
sounding answer because if a business
really needs to know how many pigs are
in China there are ways to find that out
like called Chinese pork magnate chin
Ying Lin or just Google how many pigs in
China or if you're on your phone just
Google how Kenny o and China because
that's still enough for it to go on what
do I have to do thrw the map I'm in a
hurry my thumbs are fat and I got places
to
be but once they are hired Mackenzie
Consultants work insanely long hours
while being schooled in the McKenzie way
of doing things something that the firm
itself can be pretty insufferable about
a partner once said we don't learn from
clients their standards are aren't high
enough we learn from other McKenzie
Partners a sentence so smug that even if
you just read it you'd have
automatically heard my accent in your
head cuz that's not just smug that is
British Empire smug and the thing is
that level of swagger might make some
sense if mackin's device was
consistently novel and Brilliant but
it's had some big misses famously in the
early 1980s its client AT&T asked
McKenzie to estimate how many cell
phones would be in use in the world by
the turn of the century and Mackenzie
concluded that the total Market would
only be about 900,000 phones total which
persuaded AT&T to pull out of the market
for a while and to be fair McKinzie were
only off by around 739 million or 82,000
per. but even when they are
troubleshooting existing problems their
bespoke Solutions can be blindingly
obvious just watch as one mckin brags in
a promotional video about the firm's
ability to come up with unique Solutions
we were serving in energy client and
their problem was that they uh have
offshore drilling rigs and they had
Stacks and stacks of paper invoices that
they would fly out to these rigs in the
middle of the Gulf Coast in hurricane
weather to have to get somebody to sign
off and then helicopter back to
headquarters we brought in a team that
had Partners who were experts in the
energy sector we had Partners who were
experts in procurment as a function and
they were able to get together with our
digital team and say actually we don't
know if signatures are really required D
for this
yeah no
I'm not sure speaks that well of
you that you needed the digital team and
experts in the energy sector and
procurement as a function whatever the
that means to get to the conclusion
why not send an email instead of a
helicopter and that's not a one-off over
the years they' have repeatedly been
grumbles that McKenzie oversells its
Brilliance in the words of one Fortune
story while some of its work can be
highly sophisticated much of the time
The Firm merely reorganizes sales forces
or designs buy the numbers downsizing to
reduce overhead and those are just
obvious first thoughts ideas essentially
McKenzie is a firm that projects a huge
amount of confidence to sell a
frequently unremarkable product at Sky
High prices making them truly the Salt
Bay of companies you've had salt before
but have you ever had it from a
douche and let's let's talk for a minute
about downsizing because there is a long
history of companies bringing in
consulting firms like McKenzie and very
soon after aggressively cutting costs
this gets dressed up with fancy terms
like finding efficiencies and
organizational streamlining but what
that often amounts to is mass layoffs
and look layoffs are sometimes necessary
but they're always painful and much more
painful than some mid-20s Ivy leager who
fancies himself a business genius might
realize 24 years ago Mackenzie allowed a
documentary crew rare access to film a
training session for young Consultants
going through an exercise where they
roleplayed advising a real life client
here they are joking about how they
would break the news that layoffs were
going to be necessary we got a very
simple strategy
just what do you
say that's not our communication
strategy
H look um I'm not a violent person but
if all those exploded I would
absolutely spin around singing It's
Raining Men but but that is emblematic
of a major role that Consultants like
McKenzie play essentially allowing
Executives to say I know job cuts are
bad news but it's what McKenzie told us
to do as one book on the company put it
they are without question the gold to
consultants for managers seeking
justification for Savage cost cutting as
well as a convenient scapegoat on whom
to blame it though there is one area
where Mackenzie has historically advised
the exact opposite of cost cutting and
that is executive pay starting in 1950
consultant of theirs named Arch Patton
started advising corporate leaders that
they were underpaid writing books like
men money and motivation executive
compensation as an instrument of
leadership his advice was so wildly
popular that for a Time Patton
personally accounted for almost 10% of
the firm's Billings and later came to be
seen as a major contributor to
skyrocketing EX itive pay in fact when
he was asked in the ' 80s about how he
felt about the effect of his work his
reply was simple guilty and while it's
hard to gauge tone from that I'm just
going to hope that it was a sober
reflective guilty and not as seems much
more likely a naughty mischievous
guilty I could Ed to respond to who
spikes the punch so to recap McKenzie's
advice can be expensive but obvious it
predictions can be deeply flawed and
it's arguably helped supercharge
economic inequality in this country all
of which is pretty striking coming from
a company whose leader you've already
seen sum up its fundamental Mission like
this our purpose is to create positive
enduring change in the world yeah but is
it though because let's talk about that
a quick look at McKenzie's Client List
shows a bunch of companies going out of
their way to do the exact opposite of
positive enduring change because it's
not just those oil and gas companies
that I mentioned earlier The Firm also
began counseling the tobacco industry in
1956 well after we knew smoke smoking
caused cancer you might be thinking well
come on John it was the ' 50s lots of
people were okay with smoking back then
but you should know McKenzie only
stopped working with tobacco companies
in
2021 which is and this is true too late
that'll be like finding out that Subway
dropped Jared's contract today wait he
he was still in commercials from prison
how could anyone think that this was
okay and if you think that was damaging
mckines also worked with Purdue Farmer
they actually made nearly $84 million in
fees from Purdue for advice on how to
quote turbocharge sales of Oxycontin in
fact listen to the AG of Massachusetts
explain just how intimately Mckenzie was
involved in pdue sales process McKenzie
Consultants actually rode along with
went with Purdue sales reps to doctor's
offices here in Massachusetts to
critique them on how effective they were
at selling oxyon it's true they did Ride
Along alongs and honestly I didn't think
I could have any sympathy for puru sales
reps until I learned that they were
trapped in a car with a McKenzie
consultant for hours yeah you you
mentioned that you went to Harvard can
we please just be quiet and go sell some
poison but it's not just private
companies remember Mackenzie is
frequently hired by government agencies
too where again their advice is not
brought universally positive change for
instance in 2014 New York City brought
Mackenzie in to figure out how to reduce
violence at Reiko a project whose cost
ballooned to $27 million people ask
questions at the time about whether that
was a good use of money but the head of
the city's Corrections back then
insisted that Mckenzie was worth every
penny if we made any progress it was
because McKenzie's help in areas that we
needed help in wow that is some High
Praise there to claim that Mckenzie was
the sole reason for any progress made at
Rikers would be a pretty impressive
compliment if you didn't know anything
about the state of rikus so what
imaginative strategies did McKenzie try
to implement I don't know just fun
things like expanding the use of tasers
shock guns and aggressive dogs it's some
very outside the box thinking for people
literally trapped inside boxes but his
big project was an antiviolence program
called restart and it claimed that
violence had dropped more than 50% in
the restart facilities which sounds
great and fortunately it turned out that
number was bogus because jail officials
and McKenzie Consultants had reported
jointly rigged the restart program by
stacking the units with inmates they
believe to be unlikely to get into
fights or to attack staff in the first
place and while McKinzie to this day
defends that program and denies skewing
the results it is notable that when prua
later crunched the numbers for Rikers
overall they found that jailhouse
violence there had actually risen nearly
50% since McKenzie began its assignment
and honestly you kind of got to hand it
to McKenzie there not many firms could
get paid 27 million of taxpayer money to
leave Rikers somehow even worse and it's
not just jails mck's government clients
also include Regulators which can get a
little weird when you consider that
McKenzie also represents corporate
clients for instance remember how it
worked with Padu farmer while it was
working for them it was also working
with the FDA that sure seems like a
clear conflict of interest and it was
one that even Mr positive and enduring
change here found a little hard to
explain to Congress after the fact okay
so let me ask you did you disclose to
the FDA your McKenzie's work at the same
time did you disclose to the FDA that
Mckenzie was working at the same time it
was working for the FDA that it was
working for Purdue did you disclose that
to the
FDA we made clear in multiple instances
that the individuals involved had
experience in both Pharmaceuticals and
opioid claiming my time Mr sternfels
they didn't have experience they were
the identical humans working for both at
the same time exactly and there's a big
difference between having experience
working for both and actively working
for both at the same time it's the same
difference between telling your wife
about your ex-girlfriend and telling
your wife about your current girlfriend
one is dramatically worse than the other
and casy Porter was right there there
were multiple instances of McKinzie
Consultants working for both pdue and
the FDA at the same time at one point
four Consultants working on an FDA
contract to enhance drug safety were
simultaneously working for Padu on
projects designed to persuade the FDA of
the safety of puu's product one project
even had them writing scripts for Padu
to use in a meeting with the FDA on the
safety of pediatric oxy content
pediatric oxy oxy for kids you know just
like in that episode of Dora the
Explorer when backpack is getting a bit
too heavy and Boots gives her a little
something to take the edge off now
McKenzie claims there was no conflict
there and that the nature of their work
for the FDA and Purdue was different
which is a little hard to take
considering that they sold themselves to
Purdue at the time with the notion that
they had special insights into the FDA
they told puu in 2014 that they brought
an unequaled capability based on who we
know and what we know including the FDA
who we have supported for over 5 years
so hold on McKinzie
which is it then was the work you did
for the FDA totally different or did it
help you bring an unequaled capability
to per do CU it can't be both this isn't
schroedinger's contract you can't get to
claim it's both relevant and unrelated
depending on who the you're talking
to and at this point I could stop
tobacco opioids Rikers those are already
some pretty unpleasant stains on a
company's record but here's the thing
all the examples so far are just from
the US remember McKenzie now has offices
all over the world and from them they
have cozied up to some truly terrible
clients they've worked for a Russian
defense contractor and are so deeply
entrenched in the government of Saudi
Arabia the Saudi Arabia's planning
Ministry has been dubbed the ministry of
McKenzie and it will loudly defend its
work there saying that it feels it's
making the country a better place but
that feat of mental gymnastics got a
little trickier after Jamal kogi was
assassinated just a few months later
mackin's head at the time was on CNB
trying to defend its work in the country
and reassuring everyone that had a
strict moral code the work that we do
and we think very hard about the work
that we do needs to be work that does
make a positive difference sure and
that's what I'm
for doing business with a murderer is
okay by you no it's absolutely not okay
and you and when when you find out that
your client is a murderer you do what
you walk you walk oh you walk do you
that sounds good except here's the thing
they didn't walk their client killed and
dismembered a journalist and McKenzie
responded by participating in a major
Saudi Investment conference that same
month even as other companies pulled out
so unless you walk is short for you walk
to the front of the line and pick up
your lanyard for another fun weekend at
the journalist Cho in business Jamboree
you are full of but wait wait
because it gets even worse because it
later emerged that in one of mckinsey's
reports it highlighted three people who
drove negative conversation on Twitter
about Saudi government policies this is
that Slide featuring names pictures
criticisms and follow accounts and
subsequently some of those people were
and you're not going to believe this
targeted by the Saudi government in fact
one of their phones was hacked revealing
Communications with you guessed it Jamal
kogi now at this point I have to tell
you McKenzie insists there is no
evidence the slide deck was connected to
the death of Jamal kogi or exposed
dissidents and that the deck wasn't
prepared for the Saudi government in
fact when this story initially came to
light they said the reports intended
primary audience was internal and that
they were horrified by the possibility
however remote that it could have been
misused in any way but come on it's
Saudi Arabia even if that report didn't
fall into their hands and
please what part of the way Saudi Arabia
operates made you think that a McKenzie
created list of shitalking dissidents
would be a good thing to put together
you're working in one of the routinist
toist journalist shist regimes in the
Middle East and you figured it was
completely fine to draw up a list like
this because the potential for misuse
was remote what are you talking about
this is a government led by Muhammad bin
Salman a man who and this is true once
detained his own
mother did you think that if NBS were to
stumble across a list of his hazers he'd
just send them a big no hard feelings
about all the dissident stuff Edible
Arrangement the is wrong with you
and for what it's worth a former
McKenzie consultant has called that
whole internal document excuse utter
horseshit and look McKenzie will claim
that all the examples I've given you
tonight are just isolated cases not
representative of their work overall
what's more they'll say that they've
revamped their policies on client
selection and that if a client or
proposed project falls short of our
standards we will not do the work
although they are still working in Saudi
Arabia so the standards seem at best
flexible they also want to tell
you that they do a lot of projects like
helping clients deploy vaccines or
supporting refugees and rebuilding it in
Ukraine which is very nice but think of
it like this how many uplifting McKinzie
projects like more snuggles at the puppy
Factory or make Grandma live forever
would you need to hear about to
effectively counterbalance turbocharge
the opioid epidemic help up Rikers
even more and make a Saudi Arabian
snitch list and look it's not just
McKenzie with these issues their main
competitors have had them too BCG was
also in deep with the Saudis and Bane
was banned from State contracts in South
Africa for a decade thanks to its role
in a massive corruption Scandal and I'm
not even saying the Consulting industry
should be abolished getting outside
feedback on best practices can make a
lot of sense for an organization we
certainly need to preserve a career path
for high achieving taipe bullshitters
who don't want to commit to law school
and want to spend their Prime years's
flying business class to Dallas
companies can feel free to hire as many
fresh-faced darkk sociopaths as they
want to take the heat for whatever
layoffs Andor atrocities they were
already launching in the first place
it's a free country or not depending on
where the McKenzie office is but but if
their work as they claim really does
impact the lives of millions of people
they shouldn't get to be invisible and
they should expect much more
accountability for their mistakes and
until such time as that happens the very
least they can do is be a bit more
transparent with their recruiting videos
going forward
hi there here at McKenzie we're an elite
group of strategists thinkers analysts
innovators guys named Braden and Delta
Platinum Sky miles reward members here
to drive client success in any business
venture we're proud to say McKenzie
alums include many of the most powerful
people on Earth and also Pete Buddha
judge we at Mackenzie genuinely believe
great Consultants can come from anywhere
that's why our Workforce features an
incredibly diverse array of graduates
from all over the ivy league even
Cornell so if you're an ambitious
college senior or an MBA graduate who
needs to be told you're special or you
will die we'd like you to consider a
careered McKenzie the best part of my
Harvard Education was the look on
people's faces when I said I go to
Harvard I really passionate about
belonging to groups that impress people
and so to be able to continue that at
mcken
has been very fulfilling one of the
interview questions I was asked in my
final round was how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck wood sounds like a silly question
but it's actually a smart way to test
your approach to problems and how many
billable hours you can talk for in my
case a lot here at McKenzie you'll have
the opportunity to change the world by
serving a surprisingly wide array of
clients but not just anyone for instance
we proudly don't work for tobacco
clients and haven't since the start of
this sentence we've got clients that
appeal to every interest local interests
foreign interests and even conflicts of
interest I worked for the FDA and Purdue
Pharma at the same time I can't believe
I was allowed to do that my mom did say
shouldn't that be illegal and that made
me really worried until I remembered
she's not a consultant of course she
wouldn't understand I was basically
talking to an ape we hold our employees
and our clients to a higher personal and
ethical standard core McKenzie values
will
always do you have a phone call not now
it's the
Saudis actually I do have to take this I
think it might be about the
thing you got BR
be but the point is you'll be using your
big special early 20s brain unencumbered
by practical experience to develop
thepoke tailored solutions to address
company specific needs what we're
recommending is finding significant
efficiencies by laying off the people at
the bottom of the company and paying
more to the people at the top hey that's
me with the money
signs it's me at the
top okay look we believe there are three
great institutions left in the world the
Marines the C church and McKenzie that's
because the mark of any good institution
is matching outfits evasion of
responsibility through institutional
secrecy and the misplaced belief that
you're saving the world because at the
end of the day we're Mackenzie we're
McKenzie we're McKenzie we're McKenzie
and we're capable of anything and
culpable for
nothing I love that l i mean it's true
we can't you know it can't touch us it's
true
yeah